all right cat
yes cat where'd you grow up where are
you from originally i'm la i grew up in
south central
i did
some of my youth in riverside county
also
tell me about your family
um i have a
middle class
discrete
i can say
majority educated
family
um
yeah
maybe two out of ten gradually uh didn't
graduate from high school
so
you did yes early
really yeah
how would you describe your childhood in
general
i lied on my dad when i was seven and
told my mom that he molested us
so then he quickly uh
was uh uh egg uh
removed from our life
um
so
i grew up without a dad uh i was
manipulating people since i was young
i don't know why why did you want to get
rid of your dad why that because my i'm
creole and um
my dad was uh
mentally uh abusing my mom
and i um
he was
being he was being a racist and i my
mom's first kids
uh are half black
and um
so
we're black too but
we don't look it
so
he was just mind [ __ ] my mom and i've
seen it and i loved my older sister and
i loved my
older brother and i was like
one day my mom told me a birthday party
and then
she he asked me did i like it and i said
no to make him happy and he went back
and told my mom and my mom was like i'll
never throw you a party again and she
was crying and then i just made a plot
in my head like i'm gonna get rid of his
ass
because
so [ __ ]
so so after you finish school where'd
you go from there
i wanted to be a stripper because i
graduated early and um i was 18 with uh
two kids
no i i got pregnant uh
after i um graduated from high school by
pregnant again i graduated when i was
17. got pregnant again got married at 17
um
by 18 i was like what the [ __ ]
i didn't even like my husband he was
like
a [ __ ] crabapple
he became a stripper yeah i became a
stripper and then i
uh progressed onto an escort because
one day i went in there and i made four
dollars
and i just couldn't understand it
and it's too hard to work for those
dollars when you could
easily you know what i mean cut the
[ __ ]
and the time today you were working as a
prostitute
you've been doing that for how long
since i was 19 and uh yesterday i turned
36.
happy birthday
so what
a while yeah
you have how many kids six six kids and
one grand grandkid yeah i'm nervous
about this video because uh
i don't want my kids to see it but then
again
[ __ ] it i'm just gonna let it all out so
yeah i mean yep sometimes it's best to
uh put the truth out there
do you uh
do you take care of your kids
are you raising them i was
uh i was there for all six of my kids
first i'd say at least
10 months of their life and then i um
slowly but surely
uh would uh
become an absent parent
um
i still am involved with them but are
they in my physical care no
is it because of drugs
i think the drugs have played a big part
on me they paid because i was a closet
smoker and um
i would have to make an excuse to leave
to go get high
but
more than that i think it was more just
being a selfish person
um emotions
yeah what is your drug correct no i
smoked speed
ever since i was 15 on and off
so matt
yeah and you you had pimps or you do
this on your own i won pimp
and then i became a renegade
and i booked as a cold renegade i have
all the hoes i would have i will go take
the pips hoes
and um
yeah my one pimp my baby daddy
i have four kids with him
he's now married to a a square
and um it's a spin in the face
because
i would have died for him i could have
died from him
or not for him but for the
the game the the lifestyle we lived
and um yeah
what attracts you to this this lifestyle
are you addicted to it
yeah because i know because like i said
when i i know
how
it's easy to manipulate things
if you have um
the you have the tools to manipulate
with one of them is
a [ __ ]
um
so yeah it's the easy way out
um it makes it sex sells regardless of
how it sells itself
even um
just the law of attraction you know what
i
mean
have you learned about men from doing
this kind of work what do i what what
have you learned about men from doing
this kind of work
um
that there
is i know that when a man is [ __ ] you
they're thinking about something
and it's not
you missionary and 9 out of 10 it's not
uh
uh the fairy tale with you afterwards
it's some type of uh
some people will call it kinky taboo or
something
and i just know that because i became
the dick master
and um i mastered whatever i do i master
i study i i ate it
that's what i do so when i became oh i
just aced it you know what i mean so
your skills and manipulation are
yeah you're very now so i would kind of
really manipulated john to bring his
fetish out because there is one
therefore make my job quicker because
they'd come quicker and be over with
and you have a regular probably in a lot
of cases
yeah i i i was like i call myself like a
heidi fleiss anyway
what's your favorite kind of john
what's my favorite kind of john
one that likes to
i would say
well
i don't know one that likes to um
go through use my services
to get the girls
and um
invest in
uh
invest in my
avenue of the
sex trade because it makes more sense
um
i'm funner i look better to be around
than a pimp
i guarantee a good job with my girls
i mean
you know um
i don't know i just like that
straightforward john
just a quick easy transaction yeah the
fastest
how does this kind of work affect you
emotionally
you get depressed sometimes or angry or
now i do
um
now i do i get depressed yeah because
it's like people uh
they judge you
they judge you and
even though deep in my heart i feel like
i don't give a [ __ ]
i i'm better than a [ __ ] i feel like i'm
some people feel like being a [ __ ] is
better than being a prostitute
because
that detachment to feelings but i can do
that um there's certain things that are
special and intimate to me like kissing
or having sex without protection
and
those things are sacred
and i just convinced myself that that's
what it is
you've been in love before
have you been in love before uh
is it difficult with this lifestyle do
you have those relationships yeah yeah
it's difficult with any lifestyle with
me um
that's when i become [ __ ] like i
think i can think
basically like a man and put
um
common sense before emotions usually
in everything except for when i like
somebody or i love somebody then i'm
just [ __ ] susie homemaker and i'm you
know what i mean
i'm
just skipping around baking cakes and
[ __ ] for you and just doing too much
and i'm very submissive and then people
[ __ ]
they try to i don't know
they use that against me at the end of
the day because i'm a strong entity
so
yeah makes me weak it makes me kind of
stupid
i think it's common
yeah but
it's not good for me
were there any good examples of a loving
relationship in your childhood
yeah maya jackie
mine jackie loved me so much she just
knew i was special
and she
whatever i wanted to do she believed in
me and she
would give me a quick uh rundown of how
to do it and we'd do it and i would get
it done and it would be done
no but i mean a romantic relationship oh
and romantic relationships
yeah my me and my husband my
first kid's father
when i thought i was grown
i thought that's what i wanted for the
rest of my life but
and after that i know you think the
relationship you had with your dad
has
affected the uh
romantic relationships you've had as a
as a as an adult
i know it did it sounds like you didn't
like your dad
i loved my dad
i just didn't like what he was doing to
my mom
i'm just like my dad
rest in peace
he knows it
and
i apologize before he died
we talked it out he understood why i did
that
he was just a con artist
a good one are you a con artist i can be
yeah
i can sell anything
i can convince
i can prove too i'm
i'm really good at law
but
i kind of think like a lawyer
that's i think
i don't really think i try not to think
with emotion because
that's when i get stupid
do you believe in karma
yeah
now i do i didn't before
how does karma play into your life
um all the men that want me
and i juiced them for their money and
didn't have
any concern
about hurting their feelings or
embarrassing them or humiliating that
all comes back on me with guys that i
like
they just returns the karma is just you
get what you dish out it and it's true
and
all the way
to my um
to my near-death experience
it comes back
so it sounds like you've had some rough
things happen to you yeah working tell
me about that
huh tell me about what's happened um
well uh last year i was
last year i was robbed um
and then they shot me with bad drugs and
they left me in a hotel room naked
for three days
i stayed in there naked
and then i was in a coma for six days
after that what was this um it was in
temecula at a hotel in the desert
yeah
and um
i didn't i don't have a pimp because i'm
a renegade
i just had guns usually to protect me
and whoever i'm with and i had an
entourage of you know people that i
trusted
um
i did whatever i wanted i was flossy i
boasted a lot
and i talked a lot of [ __ ]
and i
popped a lot of people's bubbles and
i was just
too much
and
i one day i got my gun taken from one of
my ex-boyfriends
and then by the end of the night i was
unconscious in all time
i wake up my feet are blocked
then i have to get them cut off my teeth
gone
my
fingertips black gone
when did this happen
uh february
22nd
of 2021
i got my
toes amputated
they were then considered dead all the
way your fingertips same thing yes from
the cold
yeah hypothermia hypothermia
and you're there for how many hours i
was three days i was naked
and um in a room with the air
conditioner on and it was october
so it was cold october that was february
i got my toes amputated
and i was in the hospital the whole time
from october to february oh i see i see
they tried to save them they were black
they were dead but
when i woke up i was like
[ __ ]
and i couldn't breathe without oxygen
i had to
get a pulmonary um
doctor found a certain steroid that
cleared my lungs
from the synthetic drugs they shot in me
yeah that's a serious setback isn't it
hell yeah
every day
it's hard were you uh
horrified when you first
saw what they had to do
hell yeah
that's perfect
yep
not even the word
i don't even know where i was just
[ __ ] heartbroken
when i seen me
who did it to you
they're in jail
not for this not for what they did to me
though before when i got out of the
hospital i i told myself i'd kill him
but it was it was a trick or job no it
was um my entourage okay it was one of
my fellow gang members and a
girl that was envious of me and
they plotted and and
caught me slipping one day i didn't have
my gun
that's a hell of a setback
yeah
people
i was such like a mean girl
i was just
conceited and didn't give a [ __ ]
and um i was a good fighter
and i wouldn't
i mean can i light my cigarette yeah
yeah
yeah okay
so yeah
i uh
people that uh they prey on me now
like because i can't move as fast as i
used to
so i've gotten robbed for a lot of [ __ ]
like since i've been um
injured
can you still work the street
yeah when i can i can't stand up for
that long but yeah
i mean [ __ ] it's hard i want it
i want my teeth fixed i want [ __ ]
i want what i used to have i want the
money back
you know
it's hard to get housing
i'm [ __ ] staying in a shelter and
then i put with
two men
might as well just stay on the street
at least i could get a hotel room by
myself to where i could bathe
so yeah it's hard
emotionally how does this affect you i
cry every day
i was beautiful
my
it's like i went to iraq or something
like i'm [ __ ] like pieces of my body
are gone and [ __ ]
not the same
people who used to be intimidated by me
are
at this point
just doing a celebration dance in my
face every day you know
here we go i gotta take a walker or
walking device
and it's just [ __ ] extra
i cry over there
but then i but then i laugh every day
too
because
it's not the end i don't care
i'm never a quitter
you can still walk pretty good
yeah i have yeah i'm i was blessed to
wear
the bare minimal
was
cut off i had a good surgeon
maybe turn towards me a little bit
yeah yeah so are you hoping to maybe get
prosthetics or something yeah yeah
somehow
um
trying to get him through medical right
now
i was supposed to go to school in may
for computer coding
i
if i pass the state bar i have a private
attorney in riverside county that will
supervise me also
but i need
and i and i would and i can't pass the
state bar and to have an attorney
actually be willing to
intern me
that's a blessing
i need my teeth fixed before i walk
beside an attorney
in the riverside court
buildings
so it's just like setbacks
yeah it's a big subject
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently i wouldn't have banged
i wouldn't have been from a gang
did the gang life lead you into
prostitution
in a way it did in a way didn't because
i always knew that
i used to i was a pimp for halloween in
middle school before i was from a gang
so i just like
i just you know i mean i like i like the
whole scenario of it but
my thing is um
gangs is such a betrayal
it's
it's so [ __ ] opposite of what it is
it just disgusts me 15 to about 20 years
of my life i wasted on a gang that
one of the people that assaulted me was
one of my fellow gang members
and did they actually did anybody
actually really come and help me to walk
or to [ __ ] do they carry me up the
stairs or anything like that
one person and he's in jail fighting
their tempting murder case
so nobody nobody from the whole gang
and it makes me sick to my stomach
so
those are the real pimps too games
yeah nowadays
yeah it's not [ __ ]
it's weird it's the exact opposite of
what the [ __ ] it is
broke my heart [ __ ]
that's why it was kind of easy for me to
become a renegade though because i was
such a
was such a
a hardcore gang member that
i didn't need a pimp
for most of my renegade um extravagant
extravaganzas
because
i had my little homies
i had homies
and i'll call them quick
and
just because if they call me quick i
would come
and [ __ ] i used that as my protection
against pimps
but still at the end of the day all the
the people that i took in and i brought
to the game and i [ __ ]
no loyalties no loyalty there's no
loyalty so
how do you think this street life has
changed
the streets are cold and they may be
cold
the streets are hard and maybe hard
the streets
have
no
what is it
i know too much like it's just no filter
i know so
the streets opened my eyes
to the evil world
so
i don't know i just don't
i don't believe in fairy tales anymore
would you want your daughters getting
into a life like that never
i will never allow that
i would never allow that for my younger
sister
i would never allow that for
any underage girl
um
[ __ ] no that's out
i'll
i'll [ __ ] the whole world before they
would have to do any of this
or ever have a pimp that was out i
wasn't accepted none of that i knew it
was wrong but it was my choice
i was just selfish because
the man that i wanted
wanted to be in that lifestyle and i
didn't want to leave his side
what do you think the most
misunderstood thing is about girls that
do this kind of work
they don't
the misunderstood thing is you say you
better save your money because
tomorrow's not promised to you
just as fast as it comes
you shouldn't go as fast as it goes
money management seems to be a big deal
for a lot of people yeah that's the
whole thing if if it was treated like a
business
and
um wasn't based on lies
then
be a normal business
but yeah money management giving your
money to a man for attention that's
where it's misunderstood
or just spending it because you have it
yeah because you think it's going to
come again like that but what if you get
blown up or what if you get attacked you
don't have feet now and you can't walk
no more and yeah
exactly
it gets
runs throughout like water and that's
crazy
are you lonely
[ __ ] yet
yep
irrelevant
but
[ __ ]
i shall ain't gonna pay for no attention
though
[ __ ] that no
i can't do that i'm still that [ __ ]
whenever
i am around somebody or somebody does
come close into my realm which is rare
now
um
they're gonna enjoy it
because
that's what i am a walking
party how do you define success
how what how do you how would you define
success
what would success look like for you
having
my own home
you're living in hotels now
yeah i just like i said i was at the
shelter i tried that motels you know in
my car are you working the internet
mansions all that [ __ ] i mean i'm still
just building a post do you just work
the internet now
um yeah
i don't even like to do that i like to
just have friends that i meet um
yeah regulars or i network you know what
i mean because i have a
my son is 19.
um
i refuse to be
just all on the internet like that for
him to find
[Music]
what's your biggest regret
missing my kid's life
missing out on the years that i can't
get back
not taking
reality for what it was and
giddy and just and getting what the [ __ ]
i needed
to be a mother
and to be
just a better person all around instead
of just feeding my emotions to make
me feel good that's all i did i spent my
money to make me feel good
spend my money to make me feel good
so i take it you have no savings
no
no
okay what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
two
don't think you're better than anybody
because you're not
we all
got faults
and
don't think
just because you look
or you think you're smarter
or whatever you can't weigh it out like
that you're not the judge bro you're the
same
everybody's the same down here
to me in my eyes and
i've seen a lot
all right cat thank you so much for
sharing your story
i wish you the best of luck with
wherever you go from here
can i have a birthday party
i'm sorry can i have a birthday bonus
yeah i can take care of you cool
thank you
you